question party is very simple you guys
in the audience are gonna ask me and
tara questions and then me and derek are
gonna answer them yeah it's gonna be fun
like a party yeah and if you have a
question just raise your hand and if we
call on you stand up and ask it ask it
nice and loud so we can hear you yes but
please do not pull down your mask we
want your questions not your aerosol
droplets
okay let's do it who has a question for
me and derek
all right let's do some hate uh this
lady in the pink shirt and glasses
thank you hi hi
i see you might be drinking tequila i'd
like to know
what is your favorite smoothie
okay okay
i did not know where that question was
gonna go it was
driving and then
[Applause]
i see you're riding a bike so
who is your favorite housewife yes
i don't know i i don't know yeah
i see that you have a beard who do you
think shot jfk
wow
i don't know i never thought it
what does one have to do with the oven
um
i am not a smoothie person
but i'll i mean
amber terry look i'm drinking tequila
all i eat is garbage i ain't no drano
smoothie
everything i eat is bad and i'm sorry
well i've i have enjoyed my short life
here
i am a smoothie person
tarik is very healthy
i get down and make my own smoothies he
said get down uh
you know uh my favorite smoothie is the
protein peanut butter smoothie a little
bit of bananas
some protein powder
peanut butter
she loves it yeah
all right okay
you got you gotta shake up that almond
milk and put them all as a base come on
well
you guys uh i hope you enjoy your
smoothies i'm gonna be out here with the
adults getting lit that's all the time
we asked the question party that was
great should we do this again
good let's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you